Composition of functions also shows how
different functions are related to one another.
In fact, sometimes it can be helpful to
figure out how we might write functions
as compositions of other functions.
For instance, let's say we have the
function h of x equals x plus 3 squared.
I'd like to find two functions f and g,
such that, f of g of x is equal to h of
x.
What do you think these two functions
could be?
Now, I personally think this is a hard
problem, but it's not a big deal at all
if this takes you few tries.
Just think about what operations are
being performed here on x to give us h of
x.
And think about what order we have to do
them in and therefore what functions
correspond to those different operations.
At the end, check your answer, by
plugging in what you have for g of x.
As the input of f, and see if you end up
with h of x.